Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at...
For me a totally new table,
and Link the same table in his home.
We're gonna be talking about,
actually we're gonna be
going through a survey
that we gave our children.
All about, mostly us.
And they didn't hold
back on their answers.
So yeah.
A survey about their
unadulterated thoughts
of one of the adults in their
lives, us, their fathers.
I will give an update
both for those of you
who are listening, because I
have every reason to believe
that I sound very echoey
'cause I am in an empty room
that literally has, it has a
rug, and it has the one thing
that has been delivered
to my office over here,
the creative house, my chair.
You're in a white room
with a white t-shirt on,
this is your office at the creative house?
Yeah, is actually not white.
It's like very very light lime green.
It's almost the same color as what is neon
that you have on but not as bright.
But I didn't really think about--
Okay.
Basically what happened is,
as I was getting ready
to shoot in my house
and then I realized that there was a dude
with a jackhammer there.
I gonna sneeze, I'm
allergic to jackhammer,
Jackhammer, your construction,
your pool construction.
The construction has resumed.
Because they're sending
like one two guys over,
they're doing it in a responsible
way, masks the whole deal.
But anyway, jackhammers and
podcasts don't mix well.
So I kinda threw everything
together and came over here.
Incidentally, just a point of nostalgia.
I am using the table.
The original card table
that we cut a hole in
for Good Morning Chia Lincoln
and then was the original
"Good Mythical Morning"
table for a few seasons.
Well before that it was the,
it was RhettandLinKast Live.
I mean, this is the first table
we made videos from for YouTube.
Oh, yeah, RhettandLinKast
Live before that, yeah.
Yeah, years before Chia Lincoln.
And you're .
It's running great shape.
I'm glad we still have it.
Oh, yes in my office, is my desk now.
As I wait for my desk to get here.
So hopefully he will--
So, I'm going
to this survey.
Just to the echo.
I've got some correlations in,
I think there's gonna be some findings
from each of these children of mine.
And I'm interested to see
what your kids had to say.
Some had to be more motivated
to participate than others.
And I think that will become clear
as we go through the responses.
You better believe it, now--
Yeah.
I've got two children,
an 11 year old and a 16
year old and it's very clear
that the 11 year old was more interested
in giving full elaborative answers.
Yeah.
Than a 16 year old,
which is just part for the
course what you expect.
The only reason I had
three kids was so now I can
have more of a chance of
picking an answer that I like
on a survey that they filled out,
which I'm talking about on a podcast.
You know, so--
Bro,
really what you're saying is that
having kids is all about
what it does for you.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It's not about them,
it's about us.
Yeah, I mean, you didn't
have to spell it out.
But I think if I get that.
I will say before we get into the survey
had a little stuff that
happened at my house.
I did a very very short
just little teeny story
on my Instagram that
let you know about this,
but I'm gonna tell you
the rest of the story now.
So, we've had this idea,
and I've heard of other families doing,
I don't know if you've
thought about camping
like in your yard, as
part of quarantine, right
I thought about for a second,
have not made any movements
in that direction, though.
Well, Jessie brought it up and I was like,
I think this is a good idea.
But I do know that it's
going to require me
to set the tent up and then
blow all the mattresses up.
I got it, I'm the dad I do all that right?
Yeah.
And so...
But I was like, okay, she
asked four or five times
and we've been in quarantine
for many weeks now.
And I was like, okay, let's do it.
And of course, we don't
even have any real grass.
We have artificial grass
in a very small, the one area
of our yard that has grass.
You told me where Barbara poops?
Yeah.
Oh Okay.
And pees, yeah.
Great place to camp
and well it makes--
In a dogs latrine.
What do you think
happens in the wilderness
that you normally camp
at, multiple animals
are defacating and--
More spread out,
it's pretty concentrated.
Micturating all over
the place.
In that one environment.
She's a small dog, if
it was a Saint Bernard,
we wouldn't be out there.
Be sleeping on some lopes.
And we've been doing another
thing which I also recommend,
we've got a projector that
we've been watching outdoor
movies on the weekends,
we've been projecting
up against the fence.
Okay.
And
watch "Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure,"
Not that excellent--
Which I had to say say.
No hold up.
We started watching that a few months back
and like the kids are like,
look at me like I was crazy.
And we had to turn it off.
No, its hilarious.
It's hilarious, your kids
don't have good taste,
I mean, it's okay.
Hey, mark here,
as have good taste.
Will find out in the survey.
You'll see in the survey how
good of a taste they've got.
My kids love insights into
the 80s and the 90s
because they'd like to see
what it was like for us.
And so like we watched "Bill
& Ted's Excellent Adventure,"
we watched "Clueless" last weekend.
They heated up and "Clueless"
is great because...
Well, but actually both of
them they take place in LA,
so it's like they get to see it anyway.
Okay.
So we were like, okay--
I'm not gonna say your
kids don't have taste.
That wouldn't be tasteful to
say, so I wouldn't say that.
So I'm saying, okay,
their taste is their own.
I was like, okay, well,
tonight is the night we'll camp out.
And Locke just immediately says,
"Well, I'm not gonna be part of that."
As a 16 year old this has been happening
as the quarantine has gone on,
he's just been kinda ducking out
of different family
activities and I get it.
Yeah, it's tough man,
for
He did watch the movie
with us, he did watch the movie with us.
But then we're like,
okay, it's gonna be me
and Jessie and shepherd.
Well you know how sometimes
things can be kinda
hanging on by a thread and
this something can happen
that can just create--
Snap.
The tension boils over.
Oh, yeah.
Well, Shepherd, at the
very end of "Clueless,"
the part where Cher is realizing
that she's in love with
her stepbrother.
Played by Paul Rudd.
I mean, this is everything
has been culminating into this moment.
And all of a sudden Shepherd gets up
and starts doing something with Barbara
and everybody gets distracted.
And then I yell a Shepherd
in the middle of the scene.
And then he is in his dragon
onesie with a giant hood,
and then he puts his head over his head
and puts his head down and
doesn't watch the last scene.
So--
Oh no.
He was upset, and then
he's like, "I'm not camping
"with you guys."
And so I tried to
talk him into it.
Isn't it you and Jessie
who gonna sleep in a tent.
So I ended up being me
and Jessie and Barbara.
All night in a tent?
Well, I'm not done yet.
So, we go out there and I'm
out there for about an hour.
And I realized that I
can't sleep and also,
my back has been doing
great, but actually that day,
my back was not doing great.
And so, I'm on one of those inflatable.
I'm not even on an air mattress.
I'm on one of those, like
packable backpacking,
very, very thin inflatable
things, you know?
And I was like, baby, I'm really sorry,
but I think I got to go into the bed.
I mean, we're just out here in a tent,
and the bed--
You're so close to the bed.
Literally yeah, I can almost touch it.
But I said--
Yeah.
But you should stay out here.
She kinda wanted to, she was
like, "Well, me and Barbara
"will stay out here in the tent."
She actually was like, she saw it as
a test.
"Can I stay outside all
night and sleep in the tent,"
'cause she was kind of
scared of what I don't know.
Okay.
So my wife slept in the tent
by herself with our dog.
And she said that was a
couple of stressful moments
where her and Barbara both
woke up heard rustling.
I think we got rats coming
down and eating fruit
from that fruit tree
in the neighbor's yard
and I think one of them may have
rustled up next to the tent.
I think that what
happened is the one thing
that makes the most sense, I mean,
you're achieving
spatial distance from your family,
the only people that you've
been in close proximity with
for weeks on in.
That's the thing about camping.
It's like, hey, we've been
confined to this space
only interacting with
each other in person.
Why don't we move to
another more confined space
and be more uncomfortable
and closer together?
Yeah.
But really, I think
what's happen is, why don't I
go and live in another house,
which just happens to
be a tent in the yard?
You're on this up?
I think you should --
Right.
Take shifts, just leave the tent up.
And that will be--
- But the tent is till out
You got a place, you got
haven that people can go to.
I might even come over there
and sleep in that tent.
I don't know about that--
I might be forced to.
But the tent is still up.
I tell this story as a way
to introduce the fact that
even though as we said earlier,
you have your children
to inflate your own ego
and to carry on your own seed.
Which I'm being sarcastic by
the way, for those of you,
for the 10%, who didn't get it.
They don't always do
what you want them to do.
The moments that you try
to create for your family, don't always
come to fruition in the
way that you envision.
And your kids they don't
always react to you,
or understand you in a way
that you are trying to be understood.
And so I think that this survey
that we we asked them
some personal questions about us,
illustrates the fact that
they do have some formed
opinions about us,
but they may not be the opinions that we
try to form in them.
Yeah, and I've got my surveys laid out,
Lily, Lincoln the middle
child in the middle,
and then Lando over here.
And let's just get into
the first question.
Let's do a couple right quick.
'Cause I think we'll just
go through the survey
and see what stands out to us.
The first question..
And Kiko and Jenna helped
put these questions together,
and then we just read them and we're like,
okay, I don't know what
they're gonna answer,
but let's just give it over
to them and see what they say.
So, the first question is,
what's your dad's weirdest habit at home?
Which I feel like, puts
a big target on my back,
'cause I know I'm a man of weird habits.
Lincoln did not answer this question,
because even though I told him a week ago,
I asked him to fill out this survey
along with Lily and Lando.
Now, I woke up this morning
and realized I forgot to
ask him again last night.
So I woke him up from sleeping.
Oh well.
To fill out this survey.
And then when I went in
there, Like 30 minutes later,
the survey was on his bed.
He was still on his bed and
he was yet again asleep.
So, it's a great sign,
the first question has no answer.
Yeah.
That seems
like the easiest one.
If you're my child, right?
But you know what?
My 16 year old did not
answer that question either.
Okay, that's right.
First question.
Lando said, "He wants to reuse,"
in all caps, "everything."
Now, I was trying to figure
out what he was referring to.
I mean, I've definitely
been reusing freezer bags.
Turn them a ziplock inside
out, rinsing it off,
letting it dry and then
putting some more stuff in it.
I mean,
I've been tempted to blow my nose
and then wipe with the same
square of toilet tissue.
I'm not gonna say
I've done that.
Hold on.
Well, based on what I
heard, while on a phone call
with you and your wife in
the background, she said,
"You just blew your nose and
wipe the counter with it."
Or no, she told my wife that
that's what you did.
Yeah.
So you have done it.
Well, I wipe my butt with it.
Well, it's not a huge
difference, it's an orifice.
Yeah, she happened to see me and I like,
I wipe my nose and then I
saw something on the counter
and I had something in my hand
and to me it was disconnected
and I know you think I'm a clean person
and I'm like neurotic about that.
But, efficiency trumps everything from me.
And like Lando said, I
like to reuse things.
So, then I had to watch the whole counter
because Christy caught me
doing that and it was just,
I don't know why I did it.
It was it just something that happened.
Lincoln didn't answer.
Lily said my weirdest habit at home is
"Eating his morning
smoothie out of a coffee mug
"and sometimes a peanut butter jar."
And I'm like, my best
mornings are the mornings
when I'm scraping the bottom
of the peanut butter jar
to make my smoothie and then
I can just pour the smoothie
into the peanut butter jar
and eat a whole lot of,
scrape the last bit of peanut butter off,
and get that much more
peanut butter in my smoothie.
Those are the best days.
You're a strange man.
I don't know where my coffee mug is.
I drink my coffee, there's a mug,
I'm not gonna dirty another thing.
I'm gonna keep using my mug.
That's not just for coffee.
Hold on so you put...
You like ration your
smoothie into the coffee mug
and over and over again,
you keep filling it up.
Yeah, I fulfill it up, drink
it, it gets halfway down.
Then I put the rest in
a scrape the blender
remains into the coffee mug.
How do you drink?
You drink your smoothie like this?
I eat it with a spoon.
I remember that now.
Shepherd only answered this question.
What your dad's weirdest habit at home.
He takes a long time to poop.
Well, you're not pooping that long.
You're just on the toilet
.
Right,
yeah I am self- isolating.
Why is that?
That can't be the weirdest
thing you do at home.
Well, I mean,
I don't know man.
I'm not nearly as
eccentric when it comes to
do strange weird little things
that I do around the house
as you, I don't have like
that "Nutty Professor" vibe.
So--
Great movie.
Yeah also "Nutty Professor" holds up.
But "Bill & Ted" doesn't .
It definitely .
As you see here are talking to you.
Definitely.
Also, you'll see as we
go through the survey,
Shepherd is also trying to be entertaining
which I believe he pulled
off pretty thoroughly.
Okay, moving on to the next question
and then we'll take a short break.
What's the one thing that
your dad always says to you?
Now,
this made me feel...
First of all, I mean, in some ways luck
and I have sort of the
typical dad-teenrelationship
and almost like a...
If you're a fan of "The Goldbergs."
We talk about how everyone in our family
is kind of like a much more
less characterized version
of the different members
of "The Goldbergs."
And so it is a very typical family,
you've got like the dad
who's always yelling
and getting upset about
people getting into his stuff,
walking around in his underwear.
So, I'm sort of a mild version
of that at home, right.
And then you've got
the older brother Barry
who's like super into basketball and rap,
and like has like,
and is always talking about working out
and all this stuff and like Locke is very
very much like the mild
version of Barry Goldberg.
Okay.
And so--
what did he say--
I think.
You would always say to him.
He said that I usually say,
"I thought maybe you weren't a moron."
Oh.
That's what you said.
I thought maybe you weren't a moron.
In first of all, I mean,
That is harsh, surely.
This isn't something that
I say on a regular basis,
but it's obvious.
It's clear that has stuck with him.
But, we do have that very
typical dad-teen relationship
in which he'll do something
and then they'll do it again,
and then they'll do it again.
And then my response will be like,
I thought maybe you weren't a moron,
which is a softer way of saying,
you're a moron, but without
saying you're a moron.
But listen, I believe in
you that you're not a moron.
But you certainly are behaving
like one at this point.
It sounds like
you've given up, like at
one point he believed in it.
But now, as a last ditch effort
to manipulate the moron out of them.
Murray Goldberg just yells moron,
I don't yell moron.
Oh he does.
I just say the constructive thing.
I try to move you away from the moron.
And Shepherd answered this as
"I think I got Corona."
That Yeah, I know you do that.
Which I did that a lot
at the very beginning.
And now it's become a joke.
So, I guess now that coronavirus is a joke
but different members of our
family thinking that we have it
as sort of become a running joke.
Anybody coughs, "I think I got corona."
Lily said that I always say,
"Hey can you turn off that light?"
I mean, I turn off a bunch of lights.
I feel like I have the
right to ask someone else
to occasionally turn off a light,
especially when I'm already nestled
into my spot on the couch,
and we're about to watch
another episode of "Survivor" together.
She's the last one, and
we've been waiting on her,
and then the light from the hallway,
shines right into my eyes.
So when I'm watching television
it makes my experience not as pleasurable.
So I'm like, hey, can
you turn off that light?
And yes, she has to turn
around and go back and do it.
But it's not the end of the world.
Lincoln said, the one thing
that I always say to him is
"Get with the program."
Yeah--
And I'm like.
That's a soft way of saying,
I thought you weren't a moron.
Well, and it definitely implies that
I have an idea of how things should go,
like you were saying about the camping.
I have a vision for how
things should unfold
and what's the most perfect
way and it's a program.
And so, I guess I think of it as
a program that people need to get with.
Now, I didn't know that
I said this all the time.
But then Lando said the one thing that dad
always says to him is
"Get with the program."
And
I did not know that this --
Wow.
Was a catchphrase of mine.
I honestly didn't, so
I'm learning something.
Apparently I say get
with the program alive.
Yeah, you never told me
to get with the program,
but I have inferred that
there's always a program.
So--
Yeah,
Maybe you just don't say it
'cause I'm not your child.
No, you're usually with
the program, that's good.
You're under my influence.
Well.
Get with the program.
Let's take a short break
and get back to some more questions.
I want you sell that shirt.
Look at this shirt, I really liked it.
Creativity through curiosity
since the first day of first grade, 1984.
You wanna, well Rhett
and I can give each other
such a hard time,
because
we've known each other for so long,
as commemorated in this
vintage neon green shirt
available at mythical.com.
Lando, you like this shirt?
True
You wanna buy?
I have to more shirts.
Apparently Lando has come over to spectate
on the recording of Ear Biscuits.
Tell him to get with the program.
Get with the program.
When you ask him do you like this shirt?
He has to say yes, because
this is how his college
is gonna be paid for.
Rhett say this shirt is
paying for your college.
Okay, mythical.com.
More question next--
What's the next question?
On a scale of one to 10,
how would you rank your dad's coolness?
Oh man, this is a risky one, right?
I think Kiko and Jenna wanted to throw us
under the bus but this one.
Lily gave me a 10 and she
even supported her answer.
She said, "he gets to do
something he loves for a living,
"and that's pretty cool."
So, the fact that I get
to do something is cool.
So I don't know if she's
really rating me as a 10,
or
my life from my perspective as a 10.
Either way, I will take it.
Yeah, that's pretty generous.
What does Locke say?
Well, Shepherd said,
"Like seven."
So like seven.
Like seven.
Lincoln, incidentally, gave me a seven.
Okay, well Locke try to
get cute and gave me a 6.8.
So I've rounded that out to a seven.
6.8.
So, I got an average
of seven from my children.
Lando gave me a 10.
And he also put four hearts
and he clarified that
it was a 10 out of 10.
So yeah,
I'm definitely Lando's favorite dad.
I think, he didn't wanna,
Lando doesn't want to make me feel bad.
I don't know what his true answer is.
Yeah, in McLaughlin
household we specialize
in making each other feel bad.
That's sort of like
we're very sarcastic--
That's love.
With one another.
Yeah, that is how we show love
to each other.
That's an expression love.
No one in a million years when asked,
on a scale of one to 10 to rank a person.
No one's getting 10s in
the McLaughlin household.
You have to do something
incredible to earn a 10
and no one's done it yet.
Yeah, yeah.
It's an emotional love lick.
Like--
Right.
I've said this before my granddad Clyde.
He give you a nice firm,
hit on the shoulder,
or like a dead leg on the knee
or give you like a firm pinch.
And that was his way of showing affection
by letting you feel
pain, just a little bit.
We caught it lovely legs.
Well, we don't do that in my house, but--
Yeah, don't do that in my house either.
Yeah, what would you
do if you swapped roles
with your dad?
Oh, what do you get for this?
Well, Shepherd said, "
I would be completely
"and utterly lost on what to do."
Hey, you know what?
That's probably true, right?
He's honest,
and then.
Is a hard job men.
I mean, I hate it, I almost
didn't say this a lot,
but it's obviously, I hate, Link.
Locke knew that we would
be doing this together
and I think he thought
this would be funny.
What would you do if you
swapped roles with your dad?
Fire Link.
Okay, that's funny.
He's funny 'cause--
As usual.
Lily said,
"Fire Lock or any of them McLaughlin's,
"just kidding hahaha."
So, it's like she has that
seems sense of humor, I guess.
But Locke, it'll never gonna happened.
Hold on, you're not joking,
she said fire Locke?
Yeah, I don't know why she
thought, she must have--
Fire Locke from what?
For one to fire me I guess,
she had a premonition.
I don't know why she wrote
fire Locke--
Yeah.
Locke guy is not even an employee.
Maybe they consulted on their answers,
I don't know.
Maybe they did.
Lando, what would he do if
he swapped roles with me?
He said, he would hand over
the company to his brother.
And then I go over to Lincoln's answer,
who did not confer with Lando.
And he said..
Well, what would I do if I
swapped roles with my dad?
"Go bankrupt."
So, no matter who--
Confidence.
Either one of them, it's
like we're in trouble
is passing the baton to bankruptcy.
Okay, if you if you choose
any guests to appear on GMM,
which guests would you choose?
Shepherd said,
"I dunno Oprah?"
Hey, that would be pretty good.
It will be kinda weird to
have Oprah on the show, but--
It's just funny that a 11 year old...
Like Oprah hasn't really been
Oprah for...
I'm saying, she just got
her own like channel.
Like, where's he getting
information on Oprah--
Yeah.
That's what I'm trying
to figure out.
I think Oprah is like a
mythological creature to him,
like someone who's just loons in the ether
as being a powerful person in society,
but he's never truly
experienced it directly,
I don't think, maybe he has.
I dunno.
Lando said his younger
cousin, that would be cute.
Lincoln didn't answer, and
Lily this is no surprise.
She said, "John Mulaney or John Mayer."
I guess anyone named John at this point.
That's what she said.
Big fan of John Mulaney.
I think maybe we could get
him on the show, I dunno.
Now, open invitation John
Mulaney, come on the show.
Yeah, yeah he should.
Interesting that Locke kinda chose like
a comedian that he's
kinda vibing with as well.
He said, "Theo von."
Theo von is funny.
I thought that it was on point
he was gonna be on the show.
Maybe before all this happened.
There was definitely talk
of him being on the show.
There is a connection with
the publicist or something,
PR firm, I think we have
some sort of connection,
but we haven't
made a connection--
He's a funny dude.
Yeah.
He's very funny.
Loose cannon, you never
know what he's gonna say.
Right.
But I like him, it'd be cool to him.
what's the one thing you enjoy
most doing with your dad?
Lando said, "Playing games,"
Lincoln said, "Laughing,"
it makes me feel good.
Lily said, "Watching Current Mood."
Again both big fans of John Mayer,
so watching his live
Instagram on Sunday nights
is something that we
now make an appointment
to watch it live, so we used to watch it
like late at night after The Fact.
But there's some about watching it live
and that's our quality time together.
Yeah, so Locke in I
have horror movie night
'cause he's really into horror movies.
His 16 year old-self,
this is how he put it.
"Watching horror movies is pretty fun."
it's like, this is what I enjoy,
it could you say watching horror movies.
It's gotta be like, watching
horror movies is pretty fun.
I mean, it's not like
incredible, but it's pretty fun.
Whereas Shep said, "Playing
with the drone/golf,"
which interesting Link,
we just got this drone
that you've now seen.
I have now seen it.
And we've only played with it one time.
I mean, I've been out like in
Shepherd stands next to me,
but I let him take the controls one time.
And apparently that meant a lot to him
because it is his favorite
thing that he does with it.
So, now I realize that,
okay, we need to...
You get insights, he's like,
really enjoying the drone.
It's not easy to control but
it's not one of those drones
that like the moment you get
it, you're going to destroy it.
Slow more reliable--
No, no.
Pretty good drone.
What kind of drone is it?
Is the Mavic Mini so it's the...
Especially like DJI,
they're the ones that make
all the best drones.
But this is like the small one.
It weighs like, it's the same...
Without a battery it weighs
the same as an iPhone, I think.
Oh wow.
Ready with a battery,
it's very, very light.
But,
it can go.
In fact, it can go two and a half miles.
And so yeah, it has two
and a half mile range.
But that's like a direct
line of sight thing.
So since, we live a
probably a mile apart or so,
Right when I got it,
I was trying to send it to your house
to spy on you in your backyard.
Like, oh there's a drone, Imma keep this.
But I just started going to your house.
And it just said signal
loss and I was like,
oh,
go down.
Break comes down.
It once it loses a signal it returns home.
How much that thing run you?
It's a nice--
Yeah, it's for 400 bucks.
400 bucks.
I would have been a little more careful
if you'd have told me
that when I was using it.
Do you thought it was...
Dude, it's a nice drone.
Modern you know.
It's a nice drone.
Yeah, it was just a little, little,
and is about as light as
an iPhone, so I'm like .
You thought it was one of
those like you get it like
the mall for like 40 bucks.
No, it's not it's...
You just went in to see the
footage from that thing.
Oh, cool, well, here's is a
test of knowledge.
I reviewed some of
the footage.
We asked each person,
how much does dad weigh?
I was curious about this.
So I'll start with the oldest,
how much does dad weigh?
Lily said, "Approximately
266 jars of peanut butter."
That's funny.
That's Way too much,
if you do that conversion,
that's way too much.
Lincoln said,
"190 to 250 pounds."
That's joking.
He dunno if he thinks that
fluctuate or what?
I don't know that he was joking.
Hold no, hold on, did he
inherit your inability
to perceive numbers?
I think maybe he did.
I think maybe be he did.
That's its crazy.
Lando,
said, "I don't know if this is right,"
question mark question mark question mark,
but ironically, he is the
most accurate in my family
with 130 pounds.
I weigh 160 packets.
I was kinda close.
Yeah, you're---
okay.
I think you were the closest,
Locke should know right?
Yeah, well Shepherd said, "125 to 150."
So not true--
Little low, little low.
Locke said, "220 pounds, 14% body fat."
Which, incidentally, that was accurate.
Totally?
Exactly accurate.
Well, Locke and I are like,
he knows this because we talked about it,
like I got my like in body--
Okay.
Like analysis done,
actually right before a quarantine.
But I've actually lost 10
pounds during quarantine.
Because I've been walking like nuts--
I've lost, at one point I lost 10 pounds.
And I don't know how or why,
and this was after a couple of weeks of
getting delinquent and not working out,
and I guess not eating,
and just wasting away a little bit.
So once I started weighing,
once I realized that,
I started eating more snacks
and I gained about five pounds back.
So, I lost 10 pounds of muscle--
Equal stats.
And I gain
five pounds of snacks,
that's where I'm at in this situation.
Yeah, but I've been looking at my walking
and I've been walking an
average of four miles per day
during quarantine.
Wait.
Yeah.
Just I mean, we've been going on walks.
I think it's a combination of that,
and then I think it's
because we've been eating
out so much less, that you just kinda make
a plate of food for yourself
and then I kinda just eat it.
Where if I go to...
Like we go out a lot,
when going out is a thing
and it's get a little appetizer.
Oh get a meal.
Let's go why not get a dessert,
get a little latte, get
a little cappuccino.
And I just think that
'cause I'm not doing that,
my calories have gone down.
So yeah, so Locke was
almost exactly right,
but not anymore.
Is there something--
okay
Your dad does that annoys you?
Locke gave me the very typical answer,
which is, "Tell me he can't
wait till I have my own kids."
Oh, that's another catchphrase from you.
Which again, is
we have so many
stereotypical conversations,
like will be in the middle of something
and I'm like, this is a conversation
that I have seen take place
in media, television and film.
And I never thought that we would get here
that you would be doing
the very teenage thing.
And I would be doing the very dad thing
and literally saying with meaning,
man, I can't wait to you
have your own children.
But you just want grandkids
that's really what you mean, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Man, isn't that a weird thought?
Us having grandchildren.
Man, I get weirded out
thinking about my kids,
like Lily having a child.
It's just gonna be...
I think that's when I'm gonna fill old.
I think that's what's gonna do it.
But grandad status.
Man, I don't know if this survey
is making me feel a little old,
is making you feel very trope-ish.
Lily said it annoys her
when I chew really loudly,
that's no surprise.
Oh, you wish you to put
that as your answer.
Lando wants a normal person.
Lando wants to change
his answer.
Lincoln said it annoys him when
I make him do his crap for him.
Well, I don't make him do my crap,
like moving the trash cans around
or like washing some of the dishes
or like turning off a light,
that's not my crap.
It's just the crap, it's all of our crap
that I'm the only one who seems
to care about besides Christy.
It's like, why is that my crap?
Yeah, the idea is that
we're trying to get them to
understand that it's their crap.
Unless he was talking--
Again.
About this survey which--
I can't wait until--
To share--
They have their own kids.
Yeah.
Lando says it annoys him when I...
He says, "when he tells me," quote,
"another way to do things."
Yeah, I get that.
He'll be doing something
and I'll swoop in and say,
I try not to say, let me
tell you the right way
or the perfect way or the
best way or a better way.
I just tried to say another way.
Apparently that technique doesn't work.
Okay, I'm taking the note.
I don't know how to take this note
because Shepherd said,
"his farts smell real bad."
What do you expect?
I mean,
yeah, I'm just a human.
And by the way, last time I checked,
Shepherd smell worse than mine.
Maybe he's projecting.
Yeah, when all you eat--
I dunno what the boy is.
is roll balls and Pringles chips.
Your farts tend to smell a little odd.
Yeah, I don't know, I mean...
In fact, many times, I'll
come into the room and say,
did you just fart?
And he's like, "How did you know?"
I was like, well, because
I can smell it son.
He's like, "Yeah, it was
like seven minutes ago, dad."
I was like, well, that's
technically just farted in my book.
Oh, really?
If a fart lingers for
seven minutes, then..
It shouldn't be more than four really.
I think you got to alter your diet
if it lingers more than four minutes.
Okay.
It just needs to kinda...
Now if you're crawling on the floor,
it's gonna settle there,
and it's gonna stink for
at least eight minutes
down there and like,
down there at the floor,
'cause that their heavy.
Is that what happens
to farts?
Yeah, hot farts kinda
they go up and then they kinda come down,
and they just form like a nice fog.
So, I wouldn't crawl a little.
It's the opposite of smoke.
But I thought,
methane goes up.
Does it?
I'm making this up.
Actually, I don't know
methane may go down.
But I think it goes up
'cause it's a greenhouse gas.
Okay, do you think the
relationship your dad has
with your dog is weird?
Shepherd said, "No, because
if he has a weird relationship
"with Barbara then I probably do too,
"although his is a little extreme."
Oh, okay, he's taking into account
how all this reflects on him.
I think the thing is that
everybody in my family,
I mean, Locke said,
"Slightly," but everyone
in my family has a very
similar relationship to Barbara
and that there's lots of baby talk.
There's lots of kissing,
there's lots of Barbara licking
people's mouth sometimes--
Yeah.
The inside of their mouths.
Oh gosh..
That's what the
McLaughlin's do, we don't--
You don't close your mouth
when you kiss your dog.
We're part of the pack,
we're part of the pack.
I think for the same reasons
Lily and Lincoln said,
"Nah," "no,"
Lando said, "a little."
It's a little weird, my
relationship with Jade.
See, we tried to get
some compliments here.
What's your dad's best trait?
Lincoln did not answer this,
Lily gave a backhanded answer.
She said, "He's pretty
smart for a YouTuber."
And of course, Lando--
That's good.
Who actually loves me.
He said, "He cares for
me," but then he clarified,
"not meaning that he takes care of me."
And weird, 'cause he's
like having another child
in the house, it's not
like you're actually--
Yeah, I--
Yeah,
I care about him, but I'm ---
Christy cares for him.
Christy cares for him, yeah, that's right.
Christy is actually raising him,
you're just being his friend.
Shepherd said...
What's your dad's best trait?
"He can make anyone laugh."
So, I'll take that.
That's thoughtful.
And then Locke gave the 16
year old version of that,
"Comedy."
he just said.
Comedy.
Best trait is comedy.
I just said comedy.
If you had to choose
one person in your family be stranded
on a deserted island with and survive,
who would you pick and why?
I'm gonna say what I think your kids said,
and you tell me what
you think my kids said.
Okay.
I mean, all this apocalyptic
and post apocalyptic
and survival talk.
I do believe that that
translates from our conversations
and also carries over into
your home conversations
'cause things are arriving at your door
and you got to explain yourself,
and you're probably proud of it.
So, I think the kids know
that you got like some
prepping tendencies.
I just think they would
both choose you even though
Jessie's the only one with enough valor
to stay all night in the tent.
True.
Well, Locke actually chose Shepherd,
which I thought this was sweet
because he said, "Shepherd
because we would never
"run out of things to talk about."
Kinda threw up on under the bus,
but how do that make you feel?
But Shepherd said, "my dad
because he has the most
"meat on his bones and
experience in life."
So he would eat you?
Yeah, well, he would take
advantage of my experience,
and then when I expired, he would eat me.
So he's definitely thinking.
Yeah, he's a smart kid.
Let's see what your kids--
What do you think they said?
I can't see your kids picking one another.
I think your kids picked a parent.
I think Lando picked Christy,
and then your teenagers picked you.
Lando
said Lincoln.
Whoa, okay.
"Because I want him to be like Kenny.
"He never will be though."
Now Kenny, the first season of "Survivor"
that we watched to season 17,
and there was this
professional video gamer
is what they called him,
competitive gamer
named Kenny.
And he turned out to be
a conniving survivalist
until he got a little cocky.
So for some reason, Lando thinks
that Lincoln's got that in.
Lincoln pickes me.
He said, "Because he has
some survival skills."
I mean, we've been camping.
So, I feel like when we go camping,
it does all hinge on me.
I'm not as helpless as one might think.
Lily said, "Probably my dad," pum!
Because I feel like he remembers the most
from that show "Man vs. Wild."
Yeah, back in the day, this is like---
Everything that you know is from that--
Six years ago, we did go
through a little stint
of watching "Man vs. Wild."
And we talked about it occasionally.
I don't remember any of it.
So, she's gonna be crushed.
Okay, this is an interesting one.
Who do you think is your
dad's favorite child and why?
Now.
Again,
this is definitely not true.
I will say that.
But Locke has this perspective.
He's like, he literally says all the time.
"Why does Shepherd get away with that?
"I would have never gotten away with that.
"Why do you let him do that?"
So, that's a very common thing.
So, his answer was "Shepherd
because it's obvious."
And I think that there is
something to the second child
getting away with more
than the first child.
And 'cause that's why you're kind of like,
I don't know, we tried really
hard to get you to do things.
And I mean, it didn't necessarily work.
And so, we're a little bit more
relaxed with the second one.
And so, there's a bunch of
resentment from the older child.
Again, very common thing.
Is interesting, I actually feel like
Lily gets away with more
or in this household,
especially in this environment,
where it's like me trying to get the kids
to do my crap, like chores.
I think Lily is the one
if I'm totally honest,
that I let off the hook the most,
because she provides the most,
I'll just call it feedback.
Whereas the boys they'll be more resigned
to what they're doing
and like washing the dishes or something.
It won't be discussed and commentary
on why they have something better to do
or something that they need to do
or there's not as much resistance.
But what did the kids say?
Lando thinks that Lincoln is my favorite.
Because he's quiet.
And my oh,
that's a good point.
That's a good point, I don't know,
maybe he is my favorite.
I am fond of the quiet.
Lincoln thought that his favorite was...
He said, "Me
because I'm the most like him."
And I think Lincoln and I, I mean,
at his age, I was quiet too.
Of course, I was the only child,
and I just didn't have anybody to talk to,
if a tree falls in the
forest, and no one's there.
Yeah, I do think we're a lot alike,
I mean, we have very
similar sense of humor
in the type of jokes that we crack,
in the expressions we make,
the way that our face looks
when we express ourselves.
Like there's a lot, we
see a lot of each other,
and people point that out a lot.
So, that's two votes for Lincoln.
And then Lily said that
my favorite was Jade.
"I don't think an
explanation is necessary."
So, two votes for Linc and one vote Jade.
Yeah, Shepard said, "Barbara,"
with no explanation.
And of course, Lando,
Imma go on record since
you're sitting here,
I'll say, of course,
you're my favorite man.
Because you're here, and
the other two can't hear me.
You know that, but you
are my favorite sometimes.
Sometimes, it shifts, right?
Yeah, is whoever's with the program.
Right, whoever is most with the program.
That's how you dish out your love.
I mean, Lincoln and I are a lot alike,
Lando melts my heart the most,
and Lily and I have a lot of fun together.
So, I think...
I mean, it does move.
But I'm not gonna say that
I don't have a favorite.
Like, parents will say,
why don't have a favorite.
I'd rather be more honest
and say he jumps around.
Well, that's not really
having a favorite though.
That's just being in a better--
Like,
what's your favorite song?
Your favorite song can
change from week to week.
Depends on what I'm doing.
That's right.
Yeah, but that to me,
that's another way of saying,
I don't have a favorite.
No, because I feel actively like,
oh, you're definitely my favorite,
I'd have thoughts like that
in certain moments.
Yeah, I don't go there.
Maybe because I've got two,
and it feels too
competitive between the two.
If I were to do that, you got three
so it feels like you can
kinda move it around.
Do you think your dad is old?
Point blank question.
Brace ourselves for the brutal responses.
Dude, I didn't get a lot here.
Shepherd said, "Kinda,"
and Locke said, "he's getting there."
Yeah, Lando said, "No,
you're mean to ask that."
Lincoln said, "Almost,"
and Lily said, "nah."
So, I feel pretty good
with this scorecard,
could have been a lot worse on this front.
Yeah.
No one came forward
and said we were old.
Well, I mean, my kids...
So, it was getting there--
Getting nearly--
Kind of.
But you're not there yet.
Right.
Maybe we'll never get there.
Okay, I thought this was interesting
because I have gone on record is
talking about my favorite
color and not having one.
What is your dad's favorite color?
Shepard said,
"When I was a little,
I repeatedly asked him
"and got I like all the
colors multiple times."
So he grilled you,
and .
Well, the funny thing
is like, I don't think that I ever said
specifically I like all the colors.
What I said is that
I take issue with the question
of what your favorite color is,
kind of like what's your favorite child?
It depends on what we're
doing, it depends on,
if it's like what I'm wearing.
It's like, well, what else am
I wearing? Where am I going?
What kind of room am I in?
So, I've gone on the
record is just saying gray
is my favorite color.
Because it feels like it's just
all the colors put together.
But for some reason, Locke
has not picked up on this.
And he just said, "Green."
He say green.
It's a strange world that we
live in when you feel like
you need to go on the
record about something like
what's your favorite color?
It's like we said things over time,
and then we have mythical
beast who kinda track
what we say and how our
stories morph over time
and things like that.
So, that's kind of part
of what you mean, right?
It's like, well, I'm on
record, saying that I'm gray.
So, now I gotta stick with that.
And before Shepherd says you're on record,
all the colors, very inclusive.
Yeah, but I think that's
his interpretation
of my actual philosophy.
I don't have a favorite color,
Unapologetically, my
favorite color is blue,
which Lando knows, and in Lincoln knows.
Lily has no clue what's what she said.
Never talked about it.
I don't think she value, she's like you,
she doesn't value favorite colors.
Yeah, color is subjective literally.
That reminds me though, I was watching...
I can't remember what it was.
I was watching some reality show
where there was some kinda
dating element to it.
And it was one of those things where
they were showing an
interview with the woman
and she was saying like,
"He's such a great conversationalist,"
and then they cut to the
footage, and the guy was like,
"what's your favorite color?"
Now it's like, this woman is starved
for a great conversation,
if she thinks what's...
Don't ever ask what's your
favorite color on a date.
Like don't do that.
I think a lot of people--
Don't answer that question.
Would determine whether a
question is a good question
if they have a good answer.
So, maybe she had like
a really amazing answer.
Well, what's a good
answer besides a color?
I mean, at least it's an opportunity
for me to give my philosophy
on color choosing,
but I still don't think
it's a good question.
No,
you could paint a word
picture you could say,
the delicate,
changing of the colors of the maple leaves
in early fall, when the sun is setting
in the west,
as it always does,
and I am dozing off
for a nice little nap in the wood.
Yeah, well, that's a good answer.
But I'm saying that the
question is a red flag.
Not that this episode is
about dating questions.
But we were telling our kids the story of
our engagement, which
we've told them before,
but like sometimes we go back through
and tell them the story of our engagement.
And we're telling this original story,
which sets up being at the Macaroni Grill,
you know the whole story.
So, we're talking about
the first conversation,
like extended conversation
that we ever had.
And then Jessie was talking about
how I was asking all these questions.
And then she talked about
how one of the questions
I asked was, if you
could have a superpower,
what would it be?
And 2020...
In 2020, I don't think
that's a good question,
like dating has changed, but in 1998
that was a pretty good question.
But you got to update your question game.
You know what I'm saying?
Like people were just starting to ask
like the superpower question 20 years ago,
you can't be breaking out
the superpower question
on a date, much less the
favorite color question.
You gotta get new questions.
Right like
if you trim your toenails,
and then you realize you need
to trim your fingernails,
do you start trimming your toenails
and start trimming your fingernails
and then go back to your toenails?
Do you finish your toenails
and then go to your fingernails
or do you wait until later?
So, that some of that
toenail gunk can just kinda
mellow out before you hit your fingers?
I don't know, that's first
date material maybe third.
What is your favorite
memory with your dad?
You're asking me this?
Sure.
What's your favorite
with your dad?
That's a different like an episode.
My dad took me to a Travis
Tritt concert one time.
We'll do that later.
And George Jones came on the screen
and sang the "Star Spangled Banner."
That was at Walnut Creek Amphitheatre.
Pretty cool.
Which question did you say
favorite memory with your dad?
What's your favorite memory with your dad?
Oh, Lando say, "Kidspace."
That's when we went
and we were climbing up
in that thing, right?
Yeah, I thought about
that as like a highlight
of the year, year before last.
I'm glad you remembered
that, thank you son.
Lincoln's favorite memory with
my dad, he did not answer.
I mean, this is page two--
Makes you feel good.
Yeah, I know page two of the survey--
You did wake him up.
You woke him up this morning.
Lily said her favorite memory was,
"Watching Supernatural," which is a show
that she was very into at the
time, "when we were on tour."
Yeah, I mean, Lily just love.
She talks about it all the time about,
last summer when Lincoln
and Lily went on tour,
she talks about that all the time.
And then there was one time when
I think we were staying
in a hotel room one night.
And I was like, tell me
about this "Supernatural,"
and so I got into the show with her.
She was kind of explaining,
she would show me one of
her favorite episodes,
and she kinda explaining it to me.
You still into it?
No, but I do understand why she's into.
Shepherd said, "Us going bike
riding when I was little."
And,
he didn't pick a specific time.
It's just that, I guess me
teaching him how to ride a bike,
which happened in California.
And then Locke said, "Hiking Raven Rock."
Really.
So, this is going
all the way back to North Carolina,
which I honestly did not really remember
that I had taken them down to Raven Rock,
past Lillington.
I guess we hiked it a couple of times.
I'd love to go back there man.
He had to be like five
years old at the time.
Oh, cool spot, a lot of good memories.
I'd love to go back make that hike
once we can do that--
Well the interesting thing about this
is this is one of my favorite
memories with my dad is...
And we would go all the time,
it was very regular thing.
To Raven?
Yeah.
Oh, cool.
He would be like...
Like after church on a Sunday
he'd be like, "Let's go to Raven Rock."
And we go and we walked down to the rock.
It was like a mile hike--
Walk back up.
Through the woods and then all of a sudden
you get to this ledge
and there's a whole rock
that then you can...
They built stairs that
you walk down the stairs
on the rock space.
A hundred stairs.
Are safe and then--
Wood stairs.
You're down at the Cape Fear River.
And an amazing
rock formation.
It's awesome.
I mean they are truly amazing,
like overhanging rock formation.
This is also my specific
favorite memory from Raven Rock
was when my dad took us
down to the fish traps,
which is the longer path
that takes you down to the upper rapids.
Right.
And he threw me
into the river to teach me
how to swim in the river.
I just got up next to the river
and there was a little chute,
little wrap in the chute
and the rapid kind--
Really.
Just like picked me up
and just threw me in there
and I just washed down the river.
Which is not necessarily
something I would do with my children now,
but it's probably one of the reasons
I like swimming in the river.
That's cool.
What is the most stereotypical dad thing
that your dad has done recently?
Lando said, "Take the ice
cream at night and eat it."
So, we've been getting special
Ben and Jerry's flavors,
and they've been monitoring closely
how much is left in each one,
and sometimes they'll go to grab it
and they'll be like, just
a little thin layer left.
And they knew there was
more than half before
'cause I snuck in at a night before,
and I ate some.
I do that, I own that.
I mean, it's ice cream in the freezer.
What am I supposed to do?
let somebody else eat the last of it?
I'll eat all of it except a little bit
and then hey, you at least get a taste.
That doesn't strike me as
a stereotypical dad thing,
that's sort of like a teenager thing,
like eating the last of something
and leaving a little bit.
That's something my teenager would do.
Okay.
Lincoln did not answer,
he was really running out
of steam at this point.
Apparently, he was already
on and off.
And Lily said, "Organize the garage."
That is my domain.
I'm due to get another organization.
It's piling up in there.
Shepherd said,
"I can't really think of one
"but I think being a dad
"is a pretty stereotypical dad thing."
Having children
I love the way his mind works--
you're dad.
Locke said,
"Talk about his knee tendinitis,"
which I really don't think
I've been talking about
my knee tendinitis very much.
I mean, I hurt my knee severely.
So, okay there you go.
In January.
Yeah, so talking about a general injury
or start talking about
something that hurts,
I guess that's a typical dad thing.
And I do talk about things
hurting a lot because things do.
It's part of it.
Yeah.
Okay,
What is one thing you've
always wanted to ask your dad.
Again, Lincoln was out by this point.
Lily said, "What is the real reason
"you drink smoothies out of mugs?"
I did not know this really annoyed her.
The reason is 'cause it's already dirty,
and it's stable to pour stuff into it
without the glass tipping over.
I mean, I have lots of
reasons for everything--
Is stable.
That I do.
Lando wanted to ask, "why did you fart,
"when you do?"
When you do.
If he had his way out I would never fart.
And I'm just...
And it's my house too.
Yeah.
So why do I fart when I do--
Do you guys--
'Cause I have a fart to fart.
Do you guys fart audibly
in front of each other?
I do, Lincoln does, that's it.
Nobody else does.
Really?
Yeah, everyone in my house does.
There are different types of households.
And I guess there's a spectrum
'cause you're kinda in the middle,
and you've got almost
half do and half don't.
I love it.
Shepherd said...
The one thing he's always
wanted to ask me was,
"Why can't we get another dog?"
Well, he's asked me that many times.
So, I guess he's just putting
it in here for one more go.
And this is very interesting from Locke.
Do you actually like the way beans taste?
Oh, yeah.
Which this is getting at...
This is an interesting thing, right?
Because there is kinda what
you were getting at before,
which is when you live your life
as a form of entertainment for people,
you say things and you do things,
you say and you do things for show.
So, I've talked about
how my hatred of cats,
I mean, I'm a dog person,
and I don't want a cat
and I don't particularly like cats.
But a hatred of cats is
something that came from
A hard take.
Being in character.
Yeah.
And so I don't hate cats.
But it's fun to make
people think you hate cats
because they get their panties in a wad
and it's entertaining to me.
All right, so is that true for beans?
Are you back to Locke word?
You don't like the taste of beans?
No, I do love the taste of beans.
And--
Really?
I love the taste of beans.
Do you have any idea how
many beans I've eaten
and how many beans I've
made during this time?
Okay, hey, I think we're
all happy to hear it.
On Saturday, I made a giant pot of beans
and most of my family eats
them as well, it's not just me.
But no, I do like the taste
of beans legitimately.
I like to taste the
beans, that's not an act,
is not an act.
Seems like Locke should know that though,
If he lives with you.
Seems a little suspicious.
I found it interesting that
he asked the question in that way.
But it's true, I like beans.
What is your dad's favorite
thing to do with his free time?
Okay.
Locke had
an interesting perspective on this,
"Stress out about work."
That's true.
So, that's his perspective
is that I'm stressing out about work.
Interestingly Shep said,
"meditate/ work more.
"He is like a working
machine, it's insane."
Wow.
They both think that you work a lot
or worry about working a lot.
And it's funny because
I think that they...
'Cause I've been at home.
Yeah.
There's no real work day anymore.
And so even on the weekends sometimes
I'll be like writing
something or doing something.
And a lot of times you're like,
"Hey, dad, "can we do this?
"Or do you wanna do this?"
And I'm like, hold on, let me finish this,
or I got to do this right now.
And I think they're just
getting this perspective that
he's always working.
Which I do work probably
more than I should.
Lando said my favorite thing to do
in my free time was, "Nap."
Lincoln said, my favorite thing
to do in my free time was,
"Sit in the hammock."
And then Lily said,
favorite thing to do in my free time was,
"Sleep outside on the swing."
So--
So,
my kids think that I work a lot
and your kids think that you sleep a lot.
Yeah.
What does that tell you?
Probably tells you
something that I didn't want you to know
which is I sleep a lot.
When you're thinking about work,
I'm swinging and sleeping.
Sorry man, sorry man.
You know what, keep it up,
don't change the thing.
It's cool, great.
No, I won't.
Okay, and now finally.
Okay, last question.
If you could pick one celebrity
to play your dad in a movie,
who would it be and why?
Lincoln and Lily bowed out on this one.
This is the Holy Grail,
this is their opportunity
to really let me have it.
Are you hearing that
Nicolas Cage is gonna play
the "Tiger King?"
"Tiger King."
Yeah.
I hope that's true.
I hope it's true.
I hear both, he'll be great.
Lando said, "I would pick Hannah Gatsby."
The Kiwi stand up comedian
who had the Netflix special.
He said, "Because her hair is like dad's"
Your youngest son picked a woman
to play you.
I mean, he's getting on the
Rachel Maddow bandwagon,
but he's taking it up a notch.
But no, no, here's the thing,
Lando does not have it in
himself to insult anyone.
So, he's not doing this as a joke.
He's doing this as his honest take
is that Hannah Gatsby
would make a great Link.
You know what, that's great,
you know what?
It's great.
I watched a little bit of the special
and then we got distracted by something.
I never went back to it but I will take it
as a sincere complement.
Well, this would be an
interesting set if Hannah Gatsby
did play you because
Locke said, "Jason Momoa."
Oh gosh.
Go to your magic.
Jason Momoa.
Jason Momoa
and Hannah Gatsby.
Hannah Gatsby.
That's a bon coming.
Shep said,
" Link because it would be interesting."
So, Shepard likes the
idea of us doing something
where you play me and I
guess I would then play you.
No, I will play you and
Hannah Gatsby will play me.
That's the take.
Well, then that would just
be twins like Danny DeVito
and Arnold Schwarzenegger.
That's wasn't though,
there's no irony in that.
That's not the point
in that movie, but I
have not seen that movie,
so I don't know--
It will be twins--
if it's true.
Without irony.
Yeah.
I don't know if twins
holds up, so I can't say,
I would suggest that.
So, what did you learn here?
What did you know?
I mean, our kids...
I think our kids are much more
a level ahead than we are.
Some of them were wise enough to know that
they didn't need to fill
out all these questions
in order to win our love, they
know that it's conditional.
And that may not be the best fathers,
but we love them unconditionally.
We love them with everything we've got.
Actually, I didn't get any
of that from the survey.
I'm just trying to project.
I would say that I didn't...
I mean, I didn't learn anything
groundbreaking.
My suspicion that my kids pick up
on things like
the trope-ish dad things.
Yeah.
Those are the things that loom large
in their memory.
So, I need to be less trope-ish.
I think I'm gonna make a short
and says get with the program.
That's good, I like that.
Okay, thank you to our
kids for filling that out.
I'm gonna close with a wreck.
And I'm going to wreck
Mike McHargue's book.
Yes.
"You're a Miracle
"and a Pain in the Ass:
Embracing the Emotions, Habits,
"and Mystery That Make You You."
Now, you know we had
science Mike McHargue,
our really good friend on GMM recently
for the leaving things in citric acid.
And,
both of us talked
extensively about his book
on our social medias.
Because...
I'm not exaggerating, and
I'm not just saying this
because Mike is a
friend, but this book is,
I think very timely, given the fact that
there's an opportunity for
introspection right now,
you're spending a lot of time
Well, with ourselves
is a lie.
With yourself.
You're always with--
Yourself but you're not...
We're sitting with ourselves a lot more.
And I think things are
coming up, it's like what?
Why am I feeling this?
Why am I acting this way?
And a lot of those questions are answered
in a benevolent way, so
you can be kind to yourself
as you begin to understand--
Yeah.
Parts of yourself that
you didn't previous.
I mean, the one of the reasons I love Mike
and I love this book is
he approaches things with
like diligently researched
scientific standpoint and it's not...
There's no whoo in this is, it is like,
this is stuff that is factual and true.
It's not some fluffy self-help thing.
It's like, this is what
science tells us about people.
And this is how those facts
about people and humanity
translate into you and your tendencies,
both good and bad.
And it's extremely compassionate
and non-judgmental.
I think,
you could
reading a book,
understand why you're a pain your own ass,
it could be indicting, but
he has a great way of it.
And this is who he is, as a person,
it's like, he's loving and accepting it.
And that translates into
how you process yourself,
which is very powerful.
And a lot of times you don't know
that you're a pain in the ass to yourself.
You're just mad, you're
mad at everybody else,
you're mad at yourself.
And you haven't even
stopped a process like,
oh, if I take a one step back
and get perspective on this,
that anger a lot of times
will just kinda melt away
when you gain perspective.
So, get it wherever books are sold.
"You're a Miracle and a Pain in the Ass."
It's also on Audible, read by Mike.
He's got a good soothing voice.
So, it's a great audible listen as well.
All right, #EarBiscuits.
Let us know if you wanna also
conduct this survey with your own kids.
Or if you don't have kids, you could,
somebody else that is
meaningful in your life.
It's a fun exercise.
So, I invite you to think
about doing that yourself.
Maybe we can post...
We could post a link to these questions
that people can print it off
for the kids in their lives.
Yeah, let's do that.
All right, we will see you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical beast.